it's really valuable what you said as
well in terms of there is no right or
wrong way it's about finding the finding
the balance that works for you and your
relationship but here's the thing most
people don't actually think about the
balance that works in their relationship
here's how most people go into a
relationship they go in their mind they
say okay my parents did it this way and
the people around me did it this way so
this is what I expect from you as a man
and a man goes yeah but my dad did it
that way so this is what I expect from
you as a woman but they don't actually
talk about it they just have false
expectations that have no communication
behind them and then they get surprised
when it falls apart but should you have
expectations in relationships because
sometimes well you shouldn't have
expectations that aren't clearly
communicated
but then if you have expectations
sometimes people really have
expectations it's like you're expecting
it to not go to plan because if you
expect something you're expecting it to
go planning if you don't that's when
people go sour that's when people be
like what's the point of doing this and
have that kind of negative attitude
towards certain things I understand I
understand what you're saying but you
have to be clear on in terms of certain
things you have to be clear on what it
is that you want in your relationship
what's acceptable what's not acceptable
what I'm saying is that most people
aren't clear on what is acceptable and
what isn't acceptable in their
relationships because they don't
actually discuss it they just think oh
well I've grown up like this so this is
what I expect but I don't actually have
that clear and this is what Hannah was
saying is have that discussion so that
you're very very clear about what it is
that both of you bring to the table what
it is that both of you want no I agree
with you and I think sometimes those
discussions do happen but again it comes
back to what you said about
accountability people don't take
accountability to actually really and
make it to what they want and what they
don't want they have an image of what
they want they have a visual of what
they think a relationship should look
like and when it's put it to the table
to them they actually think actually I
can't actually handle this I can't
actually match to what I think I can do
because they haven't been able to go
into themselves and take accountability
for what they can or cannot do facts
agreed
it's also like a lot of men want a
submissive woman but they don't have the
qualities that would make a woman submit
and also a lot of women want a man who
pays for her and provides for her and is
a good leader plans the dates but they
also don't want to do the work to be the
kind of woman that the masculine man
wants either yeah so to summarize your
your point nicely in the terms of my
personal dating experience right I got
to a point where uh where um I came back
from from uni
um a bit after I should have actually
came back from me but I came back
anyways and then I was on Tinder hinge
or whatever whatever and I was going
through my um the one night stand dating
experience right I never had a one night
stand before I came back to London after
I figured I was like 35 or whatever yeah
so women were complimenting me for the
fact that I made them breakfast in the
morning
and that to me was bewilding because
who doesn't want breakfast in the
morning
yeah but then I realized it was like am
I introductionized like am I simping for
the fact that I had a mum and my mom
always say to me if you're cooking cook
for everyone facts you know what I'm
saying so so if you're staying in mind
but but a lot of those a lot of those
kind of rituals if you like have been
somewhat lost in society and a lot of
people don't have those same those same
norms and values 100 100 but at the same
time I thought that's what makes a man a
man that's the idea that you go I don't
need to cook breakfast bro they want to
go to dick riding classes man
fighting classes I'm
just I'm as in what I can provide as a
mess I can give you what you're about to
pay 11 pounds for brunch for do you know
what I mean what what do you guys see as
Solutions in the dating Market going
forward wait do you think it starts with
the women or the men both they both need
to equally read books and educate
themselves on what the opposite sex
wants I would it would be amazing if
people can go on relationship courses
before they went on relationship before
they actually got into relationships
like I'm talking like early 20s you know
what I mean if that was like part of
like you know adulthood and you know
people would go into a career and stuff
like that but why don't you go into 90
of relationship courses are garbage they
probably are but I don't know
honestly but but I mean in terms of
maybe not you know some it would be a
course some it would be booked some it
would be
um you know personal research and stuff
like that but people don't actually take
the time to actually yeah I feel like it
would make more sense for them to talk
to someone who've been married 50 years
and most people don't have that no one
yeah and that's where the problem lies
and that's the crazy thing is I talked
to so many girls that like think it's
okay to leave just because you're not
happy
especially when you have kids and it's
it's just like my mom always told me
once you have kids it's not about you
and so I just get really confused when I
and like you're not happy I'm like the
ladies from the 1940s and 50s would
think we're so weak today like my man
had a side chick across town
I've met someone who was like oh um as
long as he
left the house at certain time came back
at a certain time and paid the bills
whatever you did in that time it's none
of my business
my my
um
no I said no I'm not gonna tell him
no it's not about me
I think I think that side I think that
side of the family would get mad
let me know I'll come back here next
week just basically basically
um there there was a a relative that
yeah if I don't say the relative I think
we'll be okay the either is a relative
of mine that she she knew her husband
was cheating right and
um basically that the the husband left
and this girl was like a devout Catholic
like she she like very much prayed every
day like the most Catholic person I've
ever met and the the husband left the
family to be with the side chick and she
prayed for a solution
side chick died
yeah and he came home yeah and they were
married like 50 plus years I mean that's
the solution
don't doubt the Bible That's what I'm
saying yeah and it's just like like the
women back then were willing to like
like she put up with that to be with him
I I that'd be a little far even for me
but maybe that's like a sign of the
times right honey you're in a
relationship yeah
and if your um partner decided actually
I'm gonna have a side chick how would
you feel about it
he wouldn't do that but if he did I
would not be okay with it okay do you
think so do you think that would be
um I'm out of this relationship yeah
so would you say that Hannah's weak if
she was to walk away from a relationship
her partner
um
no no right right now no I mean because
I think like she's in a position she can
be selective but if you have kids yeah I
think it's selfish I think like once you
have kids it's not about you anymore but
like before you have kids like before
you have kids yeah you can if you if
what if someone that's Faithful is a
priority to you and you don't have kids
involved yeah go get it there's plenty
of guys that'll be faithful I know I
know the manosphere says like all guys
cheat whatever but I know a lot as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible